welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul aka the guy who's got
those ho ho hoes and this video we're
breaking down the Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special the 40-minute
entry is packed with Easter eggs a big
twist and lots of hidden details that
set up Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3.
James gonna said that this is something
you need to see before checking out the
upcoming movie and whether that's true
or not there are still some things here
that will likely be picked up down the
line we're going to be theorizing it all
and there will be heavy spoilers here so
if you haven't had a chance to check it
out then check out now hit the thumbs up
button to spread that Christmas cheer
and make sure you subscribe to get gifts
from my sack giveaway at the end of the
video as usual and with that out the way
let's get into the breakdown foreign
special starts off with us hearing the
song fairy tale of New York by the band
The Pogues the Marvel Studios logo then
fades in and we see several panels from
Christmas themed Comics we see the thing
wearing a Santa's hat from his Christmas
special Thor flying up and dug this
strange turning a Venus flytrap into a
Christmas tree this is from the
Christmas estrange comic and it's
accompanied by the time Carol Danvers
Met Center in the story she was captured
by Grace Valentine and also toxidoxy who
kidnapped her along with a homeless man
they were carrying out human experiments
and Carol Broke Free to take them on the
homeless man was actually revealed to be
sent there and he aided Carol in taking
down the bad guys in the Marvel Universe
Santa is actually a mutant which
explains a lot and this was confirmed
further in this issue next we get a
turkey and a storefront window followed
by the time that she Hulk Met Center
She-Hulk was told she needed to find
evidence in order to convict the Killer
and she went to private investigator
Nixon Christopher which is the name
Santa was going going on there next we
get is what I believe the cover of Hulk
issue 378 Hulk looks green here whereas
that he's greater than a Christmas Day
in England however the jaw shape is
exactly the same as is the position of
Santa on top of this we also get a quick
cut of X-Men holiday special one and
this is accompanied by Moon girl and
devil dinosaur issue 37 devil dinosaur
wait you don't think
now there's some other flashes before we
pull out to the typical Marvel Studios
character Poppins which are now covered
in snowfall every time there's a new
show of film these always get updated
and She-Hulk has been added to the
letter A I think this is the first time
she's appeared in the titles as the one
for wakanda forever was dedicated
Chadwick Boseman she carries out a
Thunderclap and we see that the Marvel
Studios logo now has Christmas lights
surrounding it I love the way they've
darkened parts of the red to give it a
real nighttime feel and the shadows and
lighter bits reflecting the kind of
lights that a Christmas tree gives off
from here we go to The Eclectic AKA
yondu ship used by the ravages this
became a home for Peter when he was
younger and along with craglin he held a
Terran Christmas these flashback scenes
are animated to look like his 70s and
80s cartoon and by the looks of it
they're using a technique called
rotoscoping this involved the scenes
actually being filmed for real using
actors and then animators would Trace
over the top of them it helped give a
more fluid style of Animation to the
characters and because of the this they
move more like real people would than if
they'd been drawn wide LF played the
young quill in the Guardians movie but
here he's voiced by Luke Klein Aloha the
star in the tree is basically an alarm
light and we see that yondu doesn't take
too kindly to handouts and Gifts he
thinks Christmas is mushy and that
sentimentality will get you killed out
in space he says that if they don't get
rid of the tree then they'll be cleaning
the latrine for a year and kraglan says
but that's Jeff's favorite job you
talking back now cragland have you ever
someone you'll recognize from Guardians
2 and dear me what a disgusting hobby
you have now your new smashes the tree
like it's a like button and we learned
that Cracklin is telling this story he
says
and that's how yondu ruined Christmas
which I think might be a play on the
title How the Grinch Stole Christmas he
also brings up the multi-calendar which
is something that I don't think we've
heard about before he says it's almost
Christmas time on Earth so my guess is
that it works like a calendar across my
multiple planets see I figured it out
you wouldn't get that on another
breakdown now yeah on Earth is of course
a different length to a year on another
planet so they would need something like
that to keep this all in check as of
making this video which is Wednesday
morning because we get it sent early and
Kevin flagy has you blocked see a chump
the timeline is a bit unclear Hawkeye in
the end of no way home both took place
during the same week of Christmas and
it's possible that this is a similar
situation too with it happening roughly
around those events however it could be
Christmas of the following year but let
me know below if they've come out and
specified when this is anyway here we
find the team on nowhere and learn that
the group bought it from The Collector
this was announced in the build-up to
the project you can even see the eye
hole in the top left corner giving away
the location The Collector loves rare
and mysterious gifts and I love the idea
that he'd collect a Celestial head and
then use it as his home this would mean
he's surrounded in his own collection
and it's a really nice touch now this
was destroyed in Infinity War and the
collectors have was blown up before that
in Guardians of the Galaxy that freed
Cosmo the space dog who appeared at the
end in the post-credits scene having his
home and nowhere destroyed clearly made
The Collector up sticks and we actually
saw his ship at the start of the Loki
finale as we traveled through space it
blue past the camera showing that he's
out there somewhere we just don't know
where I don't know where thanks I'm here
all week and the Guardians are fixing it
up to make the place livable once more
and nebula agrees that hashtag yondu was
right they don't have time for frivolous
things like Christmas at this point oh
we get a little joke from Drax
I like the part where yandu kicked over
the tree
guys nipples must have hardened over the
airs as he of course used to complain
about how sensitive they were why aren't
you wearing one of Rocket's Arrow rigs
it hurts
I have sensitive nibbles anyway back on
the ground we see Cosmo levitating
panels in real life space dogs were used
by the Soviets in the 50s and 60s to see
if it was possible for life to travel in
space on November 3rd 1957 Sputnik 2 was
launched and on board was the dog like
air she became the first animal to orbit
the Earth but sadly she died within five
to seven hours of the flight from
overheating the actual cause of death
wasn't made public until 2002 with
officials saying beforehand that she
died due to lack of oxygen in 1998
olegazenko Express remorse saying that
he didn't learn enough from the mission
to justify like his death Soviets
actually launched several of these
missions into space and unlike Leica
most of the dogs did return Cosmo polls
from the comics and in those the dog has
telekinetic abilities which we see being
demonstrated here boys by Maria bakalowa
you might recognize her voice for
playing borat's daughter back all over
Bora 2.
you know anyway nice little scene with
rocket and another Earth animal
interacting well I say Earth animal we
don't know fully what's going on with
rocket but rumors surrounding Guardians
3 have said that we will see his
backstory in the film he was of course
taken and experimented on and this will
be by the high evolutionary he was
unveiled to the public at Comic-Con the
teaser trailer was shown there too and
though he can't play it here young
rocket was shown in it so maybe he
discovers his pass with Cosmo both were
experimented on and I'm expecting them
to realize they've got a lot of things
in common the next time we see them
Peter walks around and he meets rap
Miller a guitarist who writes a song
about Christmas without knowing what
it's actually about this band is
actually the old 97s and we can even see
the band member Murray Hammond wearing
his classic glasses this starts off a
Christmas jig with us getting the
classic sort of title style that comes
with Christmas specials we also see
Groot who's grown up a lot since we last
saw him he was a teen but now he's
bulked up and he's a bit of a meter also
you can see a head symbol on Peter's
t-shirt which is also on a stand by the
side guessing this represents nowhere
and the Newfound culture that's there
but let me know below if you think it
has a different meaning the song bombs
pretty bad with it talking about how Mrs
Claus works the pole and how the elves
will rise up and stab out Santa's eyes I
quite like the song mind and Christmas
specials in general are of course
littered with songs like this Jon Bon
Jovi even wrote A Star Wars themed
Christmas album with songs like R2D2 We
wish you a Merry Christmas and lots of
[ __ ] like that and at this point we get
a big reveal by mantis I feel like I
should do something why because of you
know that you ate the entire bowl of
zargonauts in the commissary other
secret that your cool sister
what drag say when trying to remain
invisible but beyond that mantis being
Peter's sister is a pretty big deal I
had to talk about the zognets first
though now as we know from Guardians 2
ego had a lot of children and nurse this
makes mantis's half-sister there was
actually a lot of things floating around
in the lead up too and aftermath of
Guardians 2 that actually spoiled this
twist in 2017 actress Jennifer Shaw
posted out a picture of her working with
Kurt Russell whilst she was wearing a
mantis costume is because she was
actually playing her mother
foreshadowing this reveal Geneva's scene
was cut from the movie but there were
remnants of it left behind when ego
walks Peter through his true plan
amongst all the people he had kids with
we can see at the back mantis's mother
and ego has stood there setting up this
reveal a while back I've always thought
the ego thing in the second movie was
similar to the reveal with Darth Vader
and Empire and Leia was of course
revealed to be Luke's sister in Return
of the Jedi so it's sort of like poetry
they rhyme with mantis now they decide
to travel to earth they kidnapped Kevin
Bacon who quill is of course completely
obsessed with he brought up the legend
of Footloose to Gamora and Guardians 1
and used to dance off as the way to
defeat Ronan in Infinity War he asked if
Footloose was still the greatest movie
ever and he's looked up to bacon since
he was a kid now at this point we see
Drax and mantis traveling out in a new
ship this wasn't in Thor 11 thunder so
my guess is that they picked it up from
nowhere has lots of seats for them so
who knows what's going on Guardians 3
was meant to release before Thor so
maybe they had something mess up in
production but that's highly unlikely as
they were still in the scripting process
now he watches they travel through a hex
point and these have of course appeared
in several other MCU movies his ways for
characters to quickly travel across
space now over at our merch website
we're having a big Black Friday sale
where you can buy any heavy spoilers
item and get an additional 25 off
something else in case you don't know I
made this company with real Rejects and
Screen Crush to bring you a nerdy way to
support our channels and also get some
sick merchandise out of it we've taken a
lot of time to make sure the material on
the shirts and how are top quality and
have a ton of different designs we just
launched this size Matters Ant-Man one
and you can get some stuff a house to
the dragon see your chump and even
through time
one link to that'll be in the
description and I really appreciate the
support thanks anyway back to the
special we get a quick scene with Kevin
Bacon who's listening to dead by
Christmas by Hanoi Rocks who watches
durantists jump across multiple hex
points and also get another Niche song
James Gunn is flexing his full musical
knowledge here and while some specials
will just go with the more cliche hit he
uses I wish it was Christmas by Julian
Casablancas this is actually a cover
song and you might recognize the
original from SNL also nice to see
mantis flying might come up in the next
film but just something that that might
also be a throwaway now they talk about
aquilis hyped Kevin Bacon up and to them
he must be the leader of all people on
Earth due to all the stories Peter told
I love how there's a woman panicking as
she sees the ship roll in and after all
the stuff that people in the MCU have
gone through you can totally see why
they'd have this reaction Drax has
forgot to put on the cloaking device but
he turns it on and the power land at the
Hollywood Sign before they head up La in
the background we can also hear the song
is this Christmas by the band The wombat
they go to the Chinese Theater which is
popped up in the MC before during Iron
Man 3 this is where an extremist
explosion went off and it put Happy in
hospital it's a far more happy occasion
for the happy holidays though and we
watch as they go on the Hollywood Walk
of Fame public seem unaware of who Drax
and mantis are but they had people
cosplaying as them at Avengers economies
Marvel so what the hell's going on Kevin
what the [ __ ] bro can't even keep stupid
pedantic details like this consistent
across 36 films and shows the anyway we
see someone dressed as Zorro Jack
Sparrow and also someone as psycho from
the Transformers Drax ends up beating
this guy up as mantis says that GoBots
killed his cousin GoBots exist in the
Transformers Universe and does does this
mean it's a it's all connected there's
also some of the Avengers too along with
Ant-Man Captain Marvel and Captain
America there's black widow too and in
the background we can see a movie poster
for Kingo if you cast your mind back to
the eternals then you'll probably
remember he had a full spy film
franchise making him basically a
Bollywood bond this is what we see here
too with a poster advertising a spy
adventure for him later on we catch
another bit of promo for the character
only this time it's advertising a
Christmas movie Kingo of course had an
apparent acting Dynasty even though it
was just him pretending to be his own
son so that he could live forever
without drawing too much suspicion
there's also a living statue and if you
look above him you'll see a poster for
hackson 3. hackson 2 was actually a
movie in the Marvel universe that was
starring Simon Williams he was played by
Nathan Fillion but unfortunately Kingo
ended up replacing Simon from hackson 3
onwards a family take a photo with them
and we're here
with the God of War Drax is of course
bald and he has red marks on his face
making him look similar to Kratos God of
War Ragnarok is a game in which you
fight Thor and Thor Ragnarok showed that
it's all connected like a pizza
and saying it for months now they take
photos with several people and it's very
similar to selfie scene that happened in
Miss Marvel at one point we can actually
also see the arm of Thor behind Drax as
he takes a pick with a hen party next
there's a guy in alphies who we see
taking photos with them in Captain
Marvel he's got ears like that and is
still taking the photo so I'm thinking
that he might even be an elf from you as
God they obviously have vacations on
Earth and we had a light elf in rooner
who too traveled out to L.A in She-Hulk
drax's face is hilarious throughout with
him just standing there looking
completely expressionless as people Pine
around him they clean up money-wise and
then head to the bar yavos this is a
possible reference to yarvo who directed
The Inferno music video for Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol 2. yet the bartender is
played by fluerborg who also worked with
gun on suicide squad he played the
character Javelin and we get some other
cameos when we get the star maps that
mantis takes after she robs someone
legit like robbed all their money and
this includes Margot Robbie and also
John Cena who too worked with guns
Suicide Squad or is it the suicide squad
can't remember a bit stupid calling two
movies the same thing but basically
moving on there's also Queen Latifah
Arnie someone got no idea who that is we
are Kevin spoiler's office we thought it
might be Zach from Saved by the Bell but
let me know below if you know who it is
lastly we go to Kevin Bacons and in a
little bit of meta commentary we see
that he's watching the 1964 film Santa
Claus Conquers the Martians this was
about Santa meeting aliens much like
what's going on here when they enter the
house we also hear the song I want an
alien for Christmas by Fountains of
Wayne they of course sang the song
Ryan's mom has got it going on and it
two ties in with the aliens chasing
bacon through the house no I know it's
Stacy's mom but it's crap joke I'm sorry
now Bacon's house number is 1988 which
is the same yeah that quill was
kidnapped and it's also the air that I
was born Drax throws mantis over the
gate and they knock on the door directly
also bacon has a guitar in his living
room which sort of sets up the end
making Girls on the Run and we watch
mantis jump through the house after him
similar how a praying mantis moves bacon
makes it to the street where the police
show up this is the first time I've seen
the pigs protecting bacon and we
actually get some similar music to Danny
elfman's Batman Returns score
tracks but it just tickles
mantis puts the offices to sleep and
this is a similar move to what she
carried out on ego in Guardians of the
Galaxy 2. they messed the police up as
badly as Riri Williams did amantis uses
her powers to make bacon want to go with
them they ask about the Fonz who quill
has also told them about and mention
Kevin's character in Friday the 13th
quill said that he killed Jason Voorhees
but in reality he was killed by Jason's
mother Pamela who stabbed him through
the neck with an arrow slowly they come
to realize that Kevin Bacon is actually
an actor which as we all know
[ __ ] sucks worst people of all time
after influences and of course YouTubers
now I'm kind of wondering how Kevin
Bacon being in the MCU works because he
played Sebastian Shaw in X-Men first
Class X-Men first Class had a young
Professor X and Professor X popped up in
Multiverse of Madness Wolverine and
Deadpool are coming in too so maybe this
is like a Ralph bonus situation where
they're different people with the same
face in different universes
I don't know shut up for a second
because because they also mentioned this
hello I'm the Batman
and I mean Hello I'm Bruce Wayne who's
Bruce Wayne now Batman and Bruce Wayne
are both mentioned coupling this with
the eternals in which there was also a
name drop alongside Superman I think
that in the MCU DZ Comics might be the
comics that they read and this is why
they're superheroes in their own pop
culture back in nowhere we see Peter and
a bar by himself and he's lured outside
by crude who along with the others has
thrown a surprise party no air lights up
covered in Christmas lights and we also
hear the song Christmas time has come by
the Smashing Pumpkins bakes Noah's
created to make it feel like a Terran
Christmas and everyone there is wearing
Christmas jumpers I love how draxus has
a cat shooting lasers out of his eyes
and they sort of create a Times Square
and have a big concert there bacon is
put in a box like a supermarket and he
and he's unveiled like a stripper and a
cake mantis lifts her control and bacon
makes a Mad Dash for it which ends in
kraglan taking him to the ship he says
what what what's that on your head
uh that is a device for controlling a
Flying Arrow and quick at the hang of it
yet at the end of Guardians 2 so I'm
practicing trying to make yondu's fly
seems like he hasn't got the hang of it
yet and I also wonder what happened to
his wife Levin Thunder had him coming
off the back of getting hitched and he
might have just humped and dumped like
the genius he is he also talks about how
the hero that inspired the hero that is
Peter Quill is Kevin Bacon Kevin gets a
call from his wife and he got reception
out there because he's been using ee the
UK's number one network he could go home
but in the end he decides to stay and
teach people about Christmas this leads
into bacon singing a song whilst the
gifts are given out group gets a Game
Boy this actually took me back to my own
Christmases as a kid rocker gets given
Bucky's arm and he of course wanted to
back in Infinity war and even asked him
about it no idea what my man is doing
now or or how nebula even got this but
let's just not ask any questions Cosmo
brings crackling the dead animal which
is a nice way to show they have a bond
and I forgot to mention earlier that the
dog is probably using a universal
translator which is how it can talk
mantis gives Drax an elf and this ties
back to him wanting to go back to
Bacon's house to get the one he took
similar sort of style and we see that
grudas created wooden dioramas retelling
the special it's the group standing on
the balcony chasing bacon and flipping
the cop car over along with bacon in the
Box lastly is kraglan holding his own
craglin who just so happens to be
holding his own craglin finally the
people of nowhere understand Christmas
and there's a lot of similarities here
to nightmare before Christmas that was
all about the people of Halloweentown
learning what Christmas was all about
much in the same vein of what this
special is too lastly mantis reveals
that she's Quill's sister which is the
best Christmas gift of all the man who
lost his mother and realized his father
was a [ __ ] dead now has someone who's
part of his actual family and it's such
a nice little tale Peter also tells
mantis how the yondu story actually
ended and we see him digging his own
present out of the trash here he has a
little figure which actually showed up
in Guardians Volume 2 alongside the
others in his collection volume on also
shot him getting a little troll from
Peter as a little troll and we Now
understand why it meant so much to him
you also see a present for a taser face
and there quill is given his iconic Guns
by yondu these are called quad blasters
and element guns in the comics which is
something that the character has
brandished in both the pair right up
into the skies together and they write
Merry Christmas and happy holidays to
all from here we get the credits which
are in red and green to hammer home that
holiday wholeness the credit scene has
screwed as a tree but he can't keep his
arms up and because he ruined Christmas
they're gonna have to have another
special not sure if that's gonna happen
though as gun is now over at DC running
thing so it is kind of unlikely for the
foreseeable future that he's gonna go
back to Marvel maybe they'll have
another character getting a special o
which will tie in with the holiday next
year so that ends the special and what a
load of [ __ ] [ __ ] that was I'm just
kidding I actually had a lot of fun with
it and now I I doubt I'm gonna watch it
again this was a nice little trip back
to the MCU in the vein of Classic
Hollywood specials it's always nice
being back with the Guardians and both
Drax and mantis are absolutely hilarious
with Dave Batista especially making me
laugh out loud a couple of times
the whole inclusion of Kevin Bacon was
great too and I love the thing being
built around its appearance Six Degrees
of Separation just got a lot easier due
to the MCU and the songs added a nice
touch to it I probably won't remember it
this time tomorrow but it was a nice bit
of content for the holidays to just keep
us chugging along until the next thing I
do kind of feel like all the projects
the MCU are doing now have really
oversaturated the brand it'll be
interesting to see what viewership for
this is like I don't think it's
necessary to see volume 3 and it's just
another stop Gap to see what characters
are doing rather than to see where the
story is going so yeah fun little thing
to watch in the morning with some nice
little Easter eggs in it beyond that
though not that deep but you know it's a
it's a holiday special so you're just
gonna get songs you're gonna get some
laughs and just some things to to keep
you watching for the 40 minutes that
it's on anyway so great glowing review
there and I'd love to hear your thoughts
if you're watching this James Gunn I did
enjoy it you know I'm just gonna say
that the positives and negatives of
trying to be balanced and I'm still I'm
still a shello and because of that I'd
love to hear your thoughts chill as well
and also let us know if there's anything
we missed did it ruin Christmas was it
okay or did it make that holiday special
thank you for any competition right now
giving away three copies of House of the
Dragons season one on the 15th of
December just in time for Christmas and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe the notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the special let me pick the comments
at random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now
save that to you then message me on tour
out heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch we've got a breakdown of
the Andor finale on screen right now so
definitely go head over there right
after this by the way thanks for
sticking to the video I've been poor you
take ASAP and I'll see you next time
peace